un gomitolo in argento 11.300 euro
ciao a tutti venuti soli dottoresse io
sono a vita è lo sviluppo diverso dal
solito andrò a comprare la cosa meno
costosa del sito di tiffany in realtà
andrò comprare il gioiello meno costoso
da tiffany perché il gioiello in una
cosa perché ho visto che su tiffany non
ci sono solo gioielli ma c'è anche una
sezione per la casa e siccome voglio
evitare di prendere qualcosa di inutile
tipo un pacco di fazzoletti li ho anche
farmi vedere qualcosa di più bello e
interessante
ho deciso di prendere gioiello meno
costoso dati pagano che il gioiello non
sia troppo costoso e non b1 pd per
sempre
ora andiamo a vedere a segue il sito e
cerchiamo assieme il gioiello meno
costoso estremamente vediamo anche qual
era l'oggetto meno costoso così vediamo
cosa avremmo preso nel caso pronti
lasciate un bel like se volete vedere
altri video di questo genere è
consigliatemi nei commenti in quali
altri siti compri la cosa meno costosa
prodi
iniziamo subito ora eccoci qua nella
pagina di tiffany
allora andiamo subito in gioielli anzi
vediamo prima quale sarebbe stata la
cosa meno costosa di oggetti non
gioielli che avremmo comprato nel caso
quindi casa e accessori si sono anche i
profumi quindi forse ma non penso che un
profumo sarebbe stata la cosa meno
costosa allora vediamo nuovi articoli
speriamo che ci sia il modo di ordinare
si prezzo crescente perfetto allora
possiamo subito vedere cosa un bicchiere
da vino rosso multiuso in cristallo
soffiato a mano 25 euro ma è fantastico
solo 25 euro per un bicchiere
però è in cristallo soffiato a mano
quindi se avessimo fatto il video in cui
comprava la cosa meno costosa avrei
comprato il bicchiere sicuramente penso
che sia la cosa meno costosa perché non
ho mai visto niente sul sito i titani a
25 euro che nei super prezzo volete
faccio comunque un altro video in cui
compro questo bicchiere se volete
vederlo insomma sicuramente una bella
idea regalo se volete spendere poco ma
comunque fare una bella figura arda c'è
che la ciotola per il gatto in
porcellana al solito porta 5 euro
ora sono curiosa di vedere come la cosa
più costosa per la casa vediamo allora
c'è una borsa questa borsa costa solo
2.200 euro ma vabbè una borsa può anche
costare tanto questa che cos'è una
padella una skoda è lì da accompagni fa
in argento a 1.700 euro
certo ho sempre voluto una scodellina
con manico in attento e poi abbiamo un
portafoto 1250 mah io voglio vedere qual
è la cosa più ridicola
c'è la cosa più assurda una penna da 350
euro all'ora sezione tiffany blu
vediamo cosa costa di più qua una che
cos'è una un gomito no vabbè un gomito
in argento 11.300 euro
cosa serve tra l'auto che conosce
è un'edizione realizzata a mano edizione
limitata dagli artigiani di tiffany nel
abbiamo reinterpretato normale gomito
utilizzando fili d'argento e lavorate
intrecciando mano trasformando
trasformando un oggetto comune in un
oggetto straordinario ma che cosa di
straordinario questo oggetto oltre al
prezzo
noi abbiamo delle valigie a 3.400 euro
ok questo è un piatto rotondo in
porcellana e argento 1550 perché chi
vuole avere degli stupidi piatti bianchi
porcellana normali quando puoi avere un
piatto rotondo in porcellana pif di blu
e argento ma ragazze attenzione perché
abbiamo un veloce un normalissimo
peluche a 500 euro
allora al primo posto vince
assolutamente il gomito in argento da
11.300 euro come cosa più costosa poi
abbiamo una brocca emergente da 6.500
euro e un fermasoldi è proprio per
ricchi questa cosa
apri mila 300 euro ma perché prendere
dei lego normali in plastica quando poi
prendere il lag in argento il il 1909
americano sono dieci pezzi tra l'altro a
2.100 euro a non potere che costruire
niente ma dieci pezzi ma perché passiamo
ai gioielli la nostra sezione allora
gioielli vediamo nuovi gioielli collane
pendenti bracciali da cosa iniziamo
proviamo iniziamo con
bracciali vediamo che presso abbiamo nei
bracciali
mi piacerebbe avere un bracciale primo
innanzitutto il bracciale che costa più
di tutti quanto costa e perché allora il
persone che costa di più è un bracciale
di diamanti il duo filo che non è il
prezzo sicuramente perché talmente alto
che hanno pensato la gente si giocherà a
vedere questo prezzo è il bracciale che
costa di più qua e un bracciale in oro
bianco con diamanti che costa solamente
78 mila euro credo di avere paura ho
paura che non troverò in niente e un
prezzo decente
ok ora partiamo da quelli che costano
meno
allora quello che costa meno è questo ed
è un bracciale a filo in argento a 160
euro quindi segniamoci questo prezzo
finora abbiamo un 160 poi oddio queste
carini simboli cuoricino 170 però costa
meno l'altro quindi per ora questo
bracciale molto semplice andiamo a
vedere inoltre categoria
vediamo a neri li anche anelli ho paura
che i prezzi siano terribili vediamo
l'anello più costoso è stupendo
ovviamente non c'è il prezzo è un
diamante gigantesco ma perché non
mettono i prezzi che di questo c'è il
prezzo
costa solamente tre 31.200 euro all'ora
l'anello meno costoso costa 170 quindi
in ogni caso costava meno il bracciale
perché costava 160 quindi già la
dobbiamo escludere questo anche se è
molto carino devo dire questo anello a
un incisione t and co tiffany computo
carino però no niente anello vediamo gli
orecchini mi piacerebbero degli
orecchini
allora vediamo innanzitutto i più
costosi sono curioso ma perché lo
mettete il prezzo ok allora abbiamo
degli orecchini pendenti platino e
diamanti dal 50 ap duro e poche vediamo
ora i meno cari
abbiamo un orecchino o che carino sa è
uno solo non sono due 160 euro solo un
orecchino in cui si situi che vuol dire
sì il francese mi piace tantissimo
perché non lo so lo trovò super carino
super elegante anche se solo uno mi
piace un sacco e dello stesso prezzo del
bracciale quindi se rimaniamo 660 potrò
scegliere se il bracciale o questo visto
che non lo stesso prezzo è decisamente
questo orecchino costituì mi piace un
sacco anche se il prezzo è veramente
esagerato perosa orecchino oggi anche
questo con scritto chissà che lo stesso
160 anche questo con la freccia 160 non
160 e sono quasi tutti i 160 anche wish
molto carino hicks o 160 questi unico
ricino molto famosi 170 quindi questi li
escludiamo allora sì amore e collane e
pendenti che penso che sia l'ultima
sezione perché abbiamo visto gli anelli
gli orecchini e le colonne si quindi
vediamo se troviamo qualcosa di meno
costoso qua
altrimenti prendiamo l'orecchino allora
vediamo innanzitutto il più costoso
allora ovviamente non ci sono i prezzi
allora ecco qua un pendente platino e
diamanti extralarge a 40 del mirtillo
video adesso il meno caro e speriamo che
ci sia qualcosa allora allora abbiamo
quale catenine che però sono solo
catenine quindi non è proprio un
gioiello completo siamo direttamente
alla collana completa e abbiamo qua ma
attenzione e 140 ed è un pendente più
catenina quindi non sto considerando le
catenine o dipendenti perché non sono un
gioiello completo a riprendere un
gioiello completo meno costoso che
prendi solo la collana de vito lungo per
forza prendere un ciondolo se prendi un
gioco lo devi per forza prendere la
collana quindi il prezzo totale voglio
sapere allora poi abbiamo il pendente
congiunto lo corre il ritorno in su
tiffany in argento piccolo 140 questo
costa meno del bracciale e
dell'orecchino quindi forse ci siamo
vediamo gli altri allora forse sono gli
stessi
sì solo che ci sono due cuoricini e un
cuoricino e colorato lo stesso 140
quindi direi che ci siamo ragazzi direi
che prenderò uno di questi 150 quindi
qua stiamo già salendo quindi no quindi
meno costosi sono devo scegliere tra
questo che è uno singolo oppure uno di
questi colori 1 questo che avrei avuto
molta scelta
comunque questo qua è uno semplice
in argento con il cuoricino la lunghezza
della catena di sotto o 16 sono indeciso
perché il rosso è molto carino ma
preferisco i colori pastello in rosa mi
piace un sacco però questo qua celeste
ha il tipico colore di tiffany che
sarebbe questa specie di celeste perde
acqua
adoro questo colore bellissimo
quindi penso proprio che prenderò questo
l'abbiamo trovato abbastanza in fretta e
vediamo se c'è qualche spesa aggiuntiva
aggiungi al carrello allora la
spedizione costa 7 euro quindi totale di
147 attenzione perché qua sotto mi dà
come consigliati questi articoli che io
non ho visto in nessuna sezione e cioè
guanti lucidanti tiffany per argento in
tessuto e parma tiffany perrucci lettura
dell'argento in tessuto tiffany blu mini
ha solo 5 euro quindi forse questo
l'articolo meno costoso ma forse non si
possono acquistare senza aver acquistato
un gioiello facciamo una prova perché
nel caso il 5 euro e pochissimo per
qualcosa ti fa neanche se solo un anno
però magari se volete fare un regalo
molto economico ma comunque carino con
la scatolina e la bustina magari si può
fare allora fidiamo
provo ad aggiungere un carrello costa 5
euro ed è praticamente solo un panno per
pulire l'argento vediamo aggiungiamolo
ora proviamo a togliere il sonno
[Musica]
sì ragazzi mi fa continuare non so
perché nella nelle categorie non ho
trovato questo articolo
però questo è decisamente l'articolo
meno costoso sul sito tiffany perché 5
euro però dovete considerare che pagate
anche 7 euro di spedizione quindi il
totale di 12 euro non so se ne vale
molto la pena per un panno 12 euro
forse è meglio il bicchiere da 25
comunque è un bel regalo ed è un
bicchiere benfatto immagino ma comunque
ora vado a prendere il sandolo e siri
vediamo una volta che arriva qua il
pacchetto è arrivato sono sorpreso
perché è arrivato un solamente due
giorni nel sito cielo scritto che
arrivava in 5 giorni lavorativi un sms
solo due giorni rotto posto andato ed è
un pacchetto molto piccolo ho visto
tempo fa degli unboxing da di dio
meccaniche avevano ricevuto punto il
loro ordine da tiffany
non so se non solo meccaniche italiani
numerico mondo di dove comunque
ricevevano anche la bustina e quindi mi
aspettavo che fosse un po più grande ma
non penso che ci siano bustino qua
dentro sicuramente c'è solo il pacchetto
andiamo a vedere insieme allora ecco qua
nella scatola su scritto tifoni e quindi
esternamente un po bruttina però meglio
altrimenti se qualcuno leggesse tifoni
anche una scatola ruberebbe tutti i
pacchi è molto carina false
il pacchetto chiuso dentro una velina ma
di tenere un po una busta se son che è
arrotolato allora ecco questo è il
pacchetto con la velina quasi un adesivo
con scritto tiffany in rilievo io non
sono abituato a dire cose costose il lux
torino fosse dovrei fare delicatamente
di non rompere niente come faccio io in
genere allora fu quasi una cartolina
molto carina siano disegno e la scatola
tiffany al centro poi wow
caspita queste la scatolina è
carinissima poi c'è la fattura un
bigliettino in cui potete scrivere voi
qualcosa oppure sarà la possibilità di
lasciare scritto un messaggio se così
fosse scritto tifoni da qualche parte
comunque il messaggio è per me da me
grazie per avermi regalato questo regalo
per cui abbiamo la bustina fifoni quindi
pensavo non ci fosse invece se eccola
qua la mitica bustina tiffany non ne ho
mai visto una così da vicino
eccola qua a qua i cordoncini quindi se
volete fare un regalo
vi consiglio di aprire la scatola e
mostrare il tutto prima di darlo il più
carino
eccola qua la andiamo adoperi vediamo un
po come questa collana è ora stato un po
la camera così vedete meglio ecco
qualche occhetto c'è un modo per
toglierlo senza scontarlo vabbè lo tiro
che carina
vediamo un po alza una sacchettina
morbida sempre stesso colore tiffany
e c'è un altro cartellino in cui dice
come prendersi cura dell'argento sembra
super delicato allora questa è la
catenina supersottile super super
sottile i ciondoli sono avvolti in un
pezzo di stoffa non si sia già rotto o
molto carino guardate sono molto lucidi
e molto carini questi soldi li perchè
sono nuovi comunque se conoscete un po
l'argento sapete che con il tempo non
perde si opacizza un pochino non è più
così lucido spero che non sia troppo
delicato perché a me piace tenere le
cose sempre addosso
altrimenti non le indosso quasi mai c'è
mi dimentico di metterle quindi se si
rovina facilmente ad esempio sotto la
doccia perché non si rovini facilmente
sotto la doccia ho letto che questo
colore qua che siano il cuoricino si
potrebbero minare facilmente rindi spero
che si veda bene è veramente veramente
carino sono molto piccoli cuoricini
forse nella foto sembravano un pochino
più grandi però sono piccolini questo e
quello con la scritta spero che si veda
e questo e quello colorato solo da un
lato
ora la prova vediamo ho scelto il
modello del della catenina più corto
perché mi danno fastidio le collanine
troppo lunghe ok eccolo qua ho messo
allora ecco qua abbassato un po la
maglia questi lo vedete sulla pelle si
vede molto il colore del cuoricino
l'altra si vede un pochino di meno ma
comunque lo trovo carinissimo perché è
molto delicato mi piacciono le cose
semplici semplici e delicate sì sono
stata contenta e super super carino poi
non so come reggerà nel tempo magari si
opacizza appunto si rovina un posto che
non si tolga il colore qua da questo
cuoricino diamo con la maglia sopra
prende comunque bene è veramente carino
quindi sono contenta non era proprio
tanto economico però per un gioiello
tiffany diciamo che
bene visto gli altri prezzi sono super
contento di questo gioiello veramente
carino fatemi sapere voi cosa ne pensate
se a voi avreste scelto un altro colore
se avreste scelto solo il cuoricino che
era un pochettino più grande o se
avreste scelto il rosa o il rosso fatemi
sapere tutto nei commenti e scrivetemi
anche se volete che faccia questo video
appunto per un altro negozio o se volete
che orsi film picchieri faccio a vedere
come comunque tutto sommato sono
contenta sono contenta che sarà anche la
bustina la scatolina è una bellissima
idea regalo e la collanina mi piace un
sacco è veramente carina
voi cosa ne pensate voi piace non vi
piace vi è piaciuto come hanno spedito
il tutto scrivetemi tutto nei commenti
lasciate un bel like se volete vedere un
altro video del genere e non mi lascio
fa giocate lines criticare se volete
vedere altri miei video di shopping
unboxing cliccate qui o cliccate qua
primi gli altri nuovi video e buona
visione